if you want to learn german check out
german uncovered a course which uses the
power of story learning to take you from
a beginner level all the way to
intermediate
click the link in the description for
more information
learners of german are often surprised
to discover just how different spoken
german can be depending on where you go
what we call german includes both
standard german and a diverse range of
dialects that differ throughout the
german-speaking regions
one of the most famous examples of this
is swiss german the dialect
spoken in switzerland they're often
different enough that speakers of
standard german can't understand them
swiss german is really a geographic
grouping of all the dialects spoken in
switzerland
rather than a linguistic grouping there
are cases in which swiss german dialects
are more similar to dialects spoken
across the border in germany
austria liechtenstein or south t-roll
than they are to other swiss dialects
that are further away
the dialects of switzerland are alamanic
dialects which is a subgroup of upper
german
there are four subgroups within alemanic
swabian
low alemannic high alamanic and highest
alamanic
it's a dialect continuum getting further
from standard german as you move
southward
in switzerland there are mainly high
alemannic and highest alamanic dialects
with a pocket of low alemanic around the
city of basel
there's quite a lot of variation amongst
swiss german dialects the speaker in
this video comes from the zurich area
in switzerland people almost exclusively
use their dialect in casual situations
as opposed to in germany where there's
been more of a shift towards standard
german
in formal situations and in writing they
use swiss standard german which is
almost the same as the standard german
used in germany with some minor
differences
there is no sharp s to represent the
sound si
it's written with double s instead some
different vocabulary is used yes even in
the written language
for example reservation instead of
reservieron
meaning hospital instead of standard
german krankenhaus
velo meaning bicycle instead of standard
german
farad meaning skirt
instead of standard german rook these
words are borrowings from french
but the real differences lie in the
swiss german dialects
including a lot of different words hello
grizzy
this is a contraction of the old polite
expression
meaning i greet you bye audi
instead of standard german choose excuse
me
excuse me this comes from french excuse
me thank you merci instead of standard
german
danke or one of its variants this word
comes from french of course
another option is merciful
means many times a little bit spitzerly
rather than standard german ambition
in standard german the verb meaning to
run is laufen
in swiss german there's the verb laufe
but it actually means
walk the verb meaning to run in swiss
german is
rane it has a cognate and standard
german
which is used more with the sense of to
race or to move quickly
by the way notice that the standard
german infinitive form of verbs ends in
n while the swiss german infinitives
don't have the n at the end
the verb meaning to work in standard
german albeit
in swiss german in standard german this
verb normally means to create
or to manage to do something those are
just a few examples there are far too
many different
words to list them all here
pronunciation one difference is that
alemanic dialects
for the most part fully underwent the
high german consonant shift
a change in consonant sounds that
occurred during the development of old
high german standard german has some of
these changes but not all
one change that most swiss dialects
underwent but standard german didn't
was the shift from ka to kha or
at the beginning of words when doubled
after r
or l and after m or n for example
thanks in standard german danke and in
swiss german
child in standard german kind and in
swiss german
that the vowel is also different being
raised in swiss german
there are sometimes differences between
monophthongs and diphthongs
listen to the words for house and pay
attention to the vowel sounds
in standard german house and in swiss
german
whose swiss german dialects did not
undergo the new high german
diphthongization
in which certain vowels became
diphthongs swiss german maintains the
monophthongs of middle high german
the long vowels
to say my house in standard german you
would say meinhouse
while in swiss german you would say miss
the plural houses in standard german
would be horizon
in swiss german it would be
conversely there are some diphthongs
that became monophthongs in standard
german
but remain diphthongs in swiss german
and each with a schwa in second position
for example the word for love in
standard german it's
liber while in swiss german it's lipi
the word for good in standard german
it's good
while in swiss german it's with the word
for foot
in standard german it's fuse and in
swiss german it's
fuss grammar another difference is that
swiss german does not have a preterit
tense
instead they use the perfect tense for
example the sentence meaning
yesterday i was at home in standard
german it's
guest unvised zuhausen word for word
it's yesterday was
i at home in swiss german it's gesture
high xc word for word that's yesterday
am i
at home bean word for word in standard
german this would be
gaston binis tsuhausegeven but it would
literally mean
yesterday i have been at home note that
e
is an unstressed form of ich when it
comes after the verb
you'll probably also notice differences
in the forms of verbs
an example that might have jumped out at
you is standard german
given versus swiss german c
they are both the past participle of the
verb meaning to be
in swiss german the verb meaning to go
is doubled when used before another verb
for instance if you want to say i go
traveling you would say
the first go here is the first person
singular present tense form
and the second one is the infinitive in
standard german you would say
a construction like this is also used
for the verbs meaning to come
and begin
is the singular imperative form and ho
is the infinitive another difference
lies in the diminutive suffix which
expresses a smaller
cuter or younger version of the noun in
standard german it's
line or hen while in swiss german it's
li in standard german a small mouse is
moist line in swiss german it's muesli
this could result in some funny
confusion because in standard german
muesli refers to muesli the kind of food
in swiss german the food is called
muesli
this difference is a result of one of
the sound shifts i mentioned earlier
the diphthong became a monophthong in
standard german
a little house in standard german it's
hoistline
or hoisin while in swiss german it's
oozly next rather than all the different
relative pronouns used in standard
german
in swiss german there's only one
relative clause marker
vo for example with the meaning of the
friend that i always
go drinking with in standard german
their friend with
emma's outfinger word for word it's the
friend
with whom i always drink infinitive
go in swiss german it's different
word for word it's the friend that i
always
with him go go drink this form is a
contraction of
vo and ich or its unstressed form
e notice that the swiss german relative
clause
has something called a resumptive
pronoun a pronoun that restates the
person or thing that you're talking
about
him refers back to different the
standard german relative clause doesn't
have a resumptive pronoun
now let's look at some sentences and see
what we find these sentences mean
we went fishing and caught lots of fish
in standard german
vagina and fingerfield fisher word for
word it's
we went fishing and caught lots fish
in swiss german it's missing a
handfulfish crown
word for word it's we are go infinitive
fish infinitive gone and have
lots fish caught first notice the
different first-person plural pronouns
the swiss german pronoun resembles the
first singular dative pronoun
in both standard german and swiss german
next notice that the standard german
sentence has the preterit tense
or the simple past tense while the swiss
german sentence uses the perfect tense
instead
as we saw before and again we see that
the verb meaning go
is doubled when used with another verb
in the verb phrase meaning go fishing
the word for fishing is also different
in standard german the usual word is
angel while in swiss german it's fiche
these sentences mean i want to buy the
kitten we saw at the pet shop
in standard germany's catsyan coffin
that's the entertainer
word for word it's i want the kitten by
infinitive that we in the pet shop
scene have in swiss german it is a hand
word for word it's i want the kitten by
infinitive that we in the pet shop
scene have first notice the different
words meaning
want vil in standard german and veit
in swiss german next we see that the
definite article is shortened in swiss
german
then notice the different diminutive
forms of the word for cat
which mean kitten in standard german
ketzgen
and in swiss german hatzli and again
notice that the initial consonant is
different
k in standard german and in swiss german
we see that same difference in kaufen
and alpha
and again we see that the swiss german
infinitive lacks the final
n next again we see the different
relative clause marker in swiss german
vo in that it again contracts with the
personal pronoun
vo plus mir becomes vomer
after that we see ide meaning in the
written as one word
then we see a slightly different form of
the word for pet shop
then we see different forms of the past
participle of the verb meaning to see
and again we see that the present tense
of the auxiliary verb meaning to have
has a different form of the first person
plural conjugation
as you can see swiss german dialects are
fairly different from standard german
of course they're closely related and if
swiss german had a different name
like just swiss we'd probably say wow
swiss and german are so similar
but because it's called swiss german the
differences stand out to us
remember that swiss german dialects are
alamanic dialects which are part of the
upper german branch of high german
some people believe that alemanic and
also bavarian
are different languages from standard
german but because they're closely
related to it and because standard
german
is the written and formal language
that's used in combination with them
they are normally considered part of the
german language
the question of the day for german
speakers outside of switzerland
how well do you understand swiss german
how different is it from your usual way
of speaking
whether that's standard german or
dialect and for swiss german speakers
how easy is it to communicate
with german speakers from other parts of
switzerland and those from outside of
switzerland
do you usually use standard german with
speakers of different dialects
if you're excited to learn german and to
be clear i mean standard german
i highly recommend you check out the
course german uncovered that i mentioned
at the beginning of the video
german uncovered was created by ollie
richards a major figure in the language
learning community who pioneered a
unique approach to language learning
using stories
you may have seen some of his
best-selling books at your local
bookshop or on amazon
his uncovered courses are based on the
same philosophy of story learning but
they're much more extensive and are
designed to take you from a beginner
level
up to the b1 level which is lower
intermediate
the course consists of 20 chapters of a
story with each chapter containing not
only a core reading and listening
section but also additional video
lessons and exercises that build on the
core material
if you're tired of boring apps and
simple grammar-based translation
try the story learning approach with
german uncover click the link in the
description for more information
right now it's time to say thanks to the
langfocus patreon supporters
especially these ones right here on the
screen because they are the top tier
patreon supporters
langfocus patrons make it much easier to
keep this channel going month after
month so many special thanks to them
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice day
you